Around 61% of all kerbside rubbish is compostable, so by using the organics bin
you can make a huge difference to what gets sent to landfill.
Let’s start with items that can’t go into
your green bin and should be put in the rubbish.
These include non-compostable garden waste
such as cabbage tree leaves and flax.
Grass clippings from lawns that have been
sprayed in the last six weeks.
And compostable packaging including corn-starch
bags such as this.
Items that say commercially compostable
can’t be processed locally
and should go in the rubbish.
So what should go into your bin?
Food scraps including meat or fish bones
compostable garden waste
and food-soiled  napkins or cardboard containers, such as pizza boxes.
All these items should be loose, not in bags
but you can wrap vege scraps in newspaper.
To learn more or to sign up for collection
reminders visit waimakariri.govt.nz/rethinkrubbish